For many Canadians like eight-year-old Maya Ray, it's kind of a ritual:...
...winding down and curling up with a good book.
Reading is great, but Maya's mom has one little problem with this.
I get upset at her.
I'm like, "Maya! Stop reading in the dark!"
So, does reading in low light really damage your eyes?
We asked optometrist Nayeem Abdullah.
I hear it all the time.
His answer may surprise you.
It's best to get the lights to be bright.
It just makes reading easier,...
...but it doesn't harm the eye in the long run, as far as we can tell for now.
Reading goes well beyond books these days, from laptops and tablets to cell phones.
Screens are getting smaller and so is the type.
For some, it's a pain in the eye.
So, we tell people to do the 20-20-20 rule.
Every 20 minutes, take a 20-second break and look 20 feet.
So, that forces your eyes to go from that converged, a status like this, to further out.
It just relaxes the eyes.
So then, you can go back to doing your job.
You can also help your eyes from the inside.
A diet high in antioxidants, berries and beans work well.
And Omega-3s, things like fish, nuts and green leafy vegetables, are great for your eyes.
And while reading in dim light isn't necessarily harmful,...
...I would tell moms to get a good light in their kid's rooms for sure.
It doesn't hurt.